[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue vous
allez découvrir tout de suite en images
les sujets qu'on a retenue dans
l'actualité est d'abord ce coup de
tonnerre dans l'automobile
l'arrestation de carlos ghosn hier au
japon alors que pensez-vous de la chute
annoncée du patron de renault nissan
on ne connaît évidemment pas encore tous
les tenants et les aboutissants du
dossier mais on comprend que pour
renault
rien ne sera sans doute plus comme avant
alors cette affaire elle tombe en plein
mouvement des gilets jaunes des gilet
jaune qui cèdent plus tôt le pas
aujourd'hui le gouvernement ne crie pas
encore victoire c'est sans doute trop
tôt et ce serait surtout très maladroit
cependant à kiel réussi à désamorcer la
crise du moins provisoirement
on va en parler la crise elle elle couve
toujours chez les maires de france qui
sont réunis cette semaine en congrès
avec le sentiment pour beaucoup d'être
pris en tenaille entre un pouvoir
parisien qu'il est négligent et leurs
administrés qui les sollicitent à tout
bout de champ vous dirai ce que vous en
pensez enfin piliers de notre république
est il en passe d'être déstabilisé le
pilier c'est la loi de 1905 de
séparation des églises et de l'état la
réforme et pour l'adapter aux réalités
des religions en france est évidemment
d'abord de l'islam est il nécessaire
c'est évidemment un sujet de débat alors
pour en parler merci d'être avec nous
les lits duhamel un vieux bouc présente
plus aux internautes de points de vue
mais quand même vous êtes juristes
politologues ahly mateur le samedi de
l'émission médiapolis sur europe 1 merci
aussi d'être avec nous et eric naulleau
vous êtes journaliste polémiste
animateur de plusieurs émissions à la
télévision
gv annuel rivière bonjour directeur de
l'institut kantar public vous êtes
spécialiste de communication politique
et vous enseignez à sciences po et enfin
pour compléter ce plateau alexis brézet
directeur des rédactions du figaro
alors on commence tout de suite avec la
page carlos ghosn à la tête de renault
qui est déjà en train de se tourner le
tsunami est donc venu du japon où il est
en garde à vue il est soupçonné d'avoir
minoré ses gains de 39 millions en cinq
ans le conseil d'administration de
renault se réunit cet après midi pour
trouver une solution mais en fait c'est
bien tout l'avenir de l'alliance renault
nissan qui est en jeu et donc peut-être
l'avenir de renault à long terme on va
voir tout cela mais d'abord on va
écouter bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie il a un mot à la bouche
stabilité en l'écoutant
autre priorité comme l'a rappelé le
présent la république c'est la stabilité
de renault et la stabilité de l'alliance
entre renault et nissan
ensuite il faut une gouvernance bien
entendu il faut une gouvernance
intérimaire donc je recevrai dès ce
matin l'administrateur de référence
philippe lagayette les représentants de
l'état au conseil d'administration de
renault pour leur demander de mettre en
place immédiatement une gouvernance
intérimaire puisque aujourd'hui monsieur
ghosn est empêché de diriger
l'entreprise eric naulleau d'abord est
ce que cette affaire elle tombe pas très
mal finalement le patron du premier
constructeur automobile qui tombe pour
vrai ouf on ne sait pas encore des
histoires financières en pleine affaire
des gilet jaune le symbole
oui symbole puisque je suppose que
beaucoup moins de gillet ghosn que de
gilet jaune
dans les rues ça c'est certain il pas
soutenu ce n'est pas une personnalité
très sympathique et surtout on a
l'impression que pour des mouvements
anticapitalistes par exemple noël tombe
en novembre parce que c'était un tel
symbole il a commencé chez michelin
comme tueur de coûts ensuite il a
demandé quand même d'énormes sacrifices
aux aux employés de renault pour en
faire la première premier fabricant
automobile et là on s'aperçoit que
malgré des émoluments qui sont quand
même considérable surtout vu depuis les
yeux de gilet jaune précisément il
trouve encore le moyen on peut parler au
conditionnel m'enfin vraiment si nissan
8 même la boîte elle-même met en cause
son patron de cette manière je pense que
le dossier est assez solide et donc
quelqu'un qui a des émoluments pareille
équipe qu'elle reproche d'avoir
dissimulé de la moitié d'avoir de s'être
livré à des abus de biens sociaux assez
considérable oui ça tombe vraiment très
mal et ça conforte l'idée d'une france
d'en haut et d'une france d'en bas qui
n'ont vraiment plus rien en commun
et franchement ça devient de plus en
plus difficile de faire société si
vraiment ce qu'on reproche à monsieur
ghosn et m
alexis ancien effectivement que le
gouvernement est un peu gênée avec cette
affaire qui tombe mal comme le rappelle
eric naulleau le côté on veut à la fois
pas lâcher trop vite carlos ghosn mais
en même temps
danseur macro pas de chance qu'il avait
mis en cause car l'ogc nice était ici
des disputes et file à un bercy côté
révisée l'académie c'était une énième
histoire de rémunération himalayas de
gone et maquereau est ici à faire
baisser de 23
donc il jusqu'à présent ils s'étaient
ils étaient plutôt affirmé dans une
souris sur aegon et puis là je trouve
qu'il ya quinze jours il s'est affiché à
maubeuge avec lui bon ça ton voyage bon
après après c'est vrai que le symbole il
est quand même désastreux il ya quelque
chose d'absolument vertigineux de se
dire des gens qui a mis autant d'argent
et c'est encore dans planquer et de se
dire quelqu'un qui par ailleurs est un
chef d'entreprise absolument
extraordinaire on peut être un sale
bonhomme est un très grand chai dans les
allées des apparemment il a réussi à
bâtir une chose d'extra bien mais qui
met en danger tout ça pour quelques
millions de plus alors qu'il en attend
c'est mais c'est sans doute qu'il ne
faut pas avoir ces millions pour se
poser cette question elle sent trahi à
la présomption d'innocence
sans doute très attaché c'est quoi c'est
un sentiment d'impunité toujours moi je
ne comprenais pas comment c'était
possible un truc pareil quand vous
gagnez 3 millions d'euros par semaine
3 millions d'euros par semaine comment
vous pouvez encore en chercher alors
j'ai été regardé du côté des philosophes
j'ai trouvé l'explication chez un
philosophe de droite plus tas de pognon
- tas de principe
l'oseille c'est la gangrène de lââm
jérôme rivière sur ce que sur ce côté
quand même mal venue et emmanuel pardon
si c'est bon oui là le côté ce qu est ce
qu on rappelle tous c'est ça tombe mal
oui ça tombe mal parce que effectivement
comme cela a été rappelé dans un
contexte où il ya un tout petit peu de
tension sur les sur les questions
fiscales qui viennent s'ajouter une
tension qu'on avait mesuré d'ailleurs
cet été dans une enquête sur les
inégalités ressenti était frappant de
voir que plus encore que l'inégalité
entre les riches et les pauvres les gens
ressentaient une inégalité des conflits
entre les dirigeants et en gros les gens
dorment ou est là c'est pour ça que ça
pose problème d'ailleurs pas simplement
à la stabilité
de renault on comprend que bono le maire
prenne cette clé d'entrée pour montrer
que le gouvernement réagit quelque part
ça pose la question aux gens qui sont
ces gens qui me griffe pour les raisons
que vous ne l'ayez il vous dit vraiment
dans un monde totalement différent et
c'est là où ça devient plus dangereuse
je pense que autrefois parce que il ya
aussi une porosité entre les différents
publics
il ya différents publics qui sont
touchés est concerné par ça et qu'ils
s'expriment les citoyens français jockey
éventuellement les clients ce qu'ils
prennent petit à faire dans une
industrie automobile qui a un peu marqué
par quelques affaires et les salariés de
renault qui ont été les premiers à
s'exprimer de manière plus ou moins
spontanés pour dire aussi leur animation
donc il ya aussi un enjeu de management
de derrière derrière ces transformations
importantes que rappelait alexis brézet
s'il ya la dimension de l'éthique qui
est très attaquée tout le reste est
fragilisé alexis a là encore on connaît
pas l'anc est précisément mais on se dit
aussi que bon les japonais nissan a
peut-être peut-être intérêt à écarter
carlos ghosn dans une période où
finalement il a sauvé nissan et
maintenant on n'a plus besoin de lui en
tout cas qu'en juin quand on pense que
depuis des années on sera content et
qu'il ya une très grande réussite
quitter cette fameuse alliance qui
reposait dont on pensait qu'elle
reposait sur carlos ghosn et les liens
que carlos ghosn avait réussi à tisser
personnellement avec le management
japonais lance dick qui sait bien qu'on
s'est trompé du tout tout tout est parce
que cet ensemble et claque pas non mais
vous bien voir qu'elles n'éclatent
c'est un dossier qui instruit de la
direction générale c'est que tous les
collaborateurs de gones qui depuis des
mois sont censés être
ses fidèles et le soutenir et c'est sans
doute depuis un certain temps
instruisent se refuse à sion la
signalent à la police pour le jour où ça
éclate pouvoir dire c'est plus possible
donc ça veut dire que ça fait longtemps
que ça couve et qu'il n'a rien vu et
maintenant du coup est ce que cette
fameuse alliance dans ces conditions-là
peu dans quelles conditions peut-elle
durer alors renault atteint 44% du
capital de nissan donc ça se défait pas
d'un clin d'oeil mais en tout cas les
liens de menaces managériaux entre d'un
côté les japonais l'autre côté les
français on les sent pas bien ça
rappelle un peu la faire des escales
puisque lui à la descente d'un avion et
lui c'était à l'entrée d'un avion mais
ont tout de suite on a un peu opté pour
la théorie du complot en disant mais ce
que bon alors là j'ai pas été clair
c'est pas parce que quelque chose est
utilisée que c'est faux rappelez vous
l'histoire fillon on disait celles qui
l'utilisaient la n'exclut pas l'autre
jeudi la mairie de malo à aucun moment
je ne dis que les parents ils ont
inventé des choses mais moi je suis au
travail ça révèle une différence
culturelle majeure entre la france et le
japon
c'est que au japon il ya des choses qui
en france sont un peut tolérer et crois
pas je crois quand le patron de la sncf
du japon organise une conférence de
presse pour s'excuser qu'un train soit
parti cinq secondes avant le sien une
honte nationale
je crois qu'il ya des formes des tic
dans le patronat japonais dont on est
très élevé dans un mois ou deux la
hongrie mais jeu pareil je découvre un
peu de cette affaire c'est que notamment
sur la question des frais professionnels
au contraire les japonais sont en tout
quelque chose de très élastique et qu'on
peut les frères main dans le château de
le dit joliment la question du point
d'honneur de la perte de face asiatiques
ou japonaise est pas exactement une
chose que les questions de juridique et
le jeu on dit que il ya dans la jurée
dans la législation japonaise toute une
série de 2
deux choses qui aujourd'hui serait qu'il
serait pas autorisée en france mais ça
prouve juste la pertinence de ma théorie
des zones de cerveau disponible et que
quelqu'un qui peut apparaître comme
extrêmement intelligent et avoir les
bonnes zones pour créer un truc
incroyable comme on y sent un certain
andy beal au point encore plus s'il est
fragile parce que s'il est fragile il le
sait il est fragile c'est impossible
pour ces difficultés alors soit il ne le
sait pas ça fait toute une zone de plus
qu'il en soit il le sait mais il se
surestime tellement qu'ils arrêtent pas
essayer la zone d'à côté qui manque ou
alors la toute-puissance fait croire que
tout est permis
voilà je crois qu'à un moment c'est ça
la connerie tirer c'est la connerie
c'est une forme de bêtise
en fait ce qui sera probablement la clé
de lecture qui s'imposera et je vous
demande si on peut pas spéculer sur
l'interprétation que vous faisiez c'est
à dire que beaucoup de français vont se
dire c'est arrivé au japon parce que ici
on ne fait pas ce genre de choses aux
puissants quand il quand il trichait
c'est peut-être une clé de lecture qui
finissent aussi par se surajouter il a
pas beaucoup
d'abord il ya je ne sais pas s'il ya un
seul patron français qui touche les
sommes plutôt chez les perdants secondes
deuxièmement malgré ce que dit on
philosophe l'oseille c'est la gangrène
de larmes est tous ne sont pas blancs
grenelle environnement
mais est-ce qu'ils avaient pas parce que
déjà des petites pistes de manuel macron
quand effectivement vous le rappeliez
alexis
d'où trois ans avait commencé un petit
peu a tapé du poing sur la table en
disant ça va c'est trop fort il avait
aussi dit à carlos ghosn préparer votre
succession
berti bayard le rappelle la faim dans un
papier publié demain elle dit il avait
dit il faut commencer à réfléchir à
l'après gones et tout ça et qu'il
n'avait pas été très entendu à l'époque
il avait il a l'intuition chez renault
qui ont oublié tant que maître bolloré
média et nareg football aurait et puis
il avait un bras droit au japon qui est
l'homme qui a le premier aujourd'hui le
plus probable c'est que ce soit le
premier qui en tout cas à titre
provisoire prenne intérim après c'est le
conseil d'admistration qui si tout ça va
plus loin et ça a l'air bien c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle parce que pendant ce
temps là l'action renault compte c'est
quand même catastrophique 4 au delà il
ya d'abord la question symbolique tout
ce qu'on dit en ce moment sur le climat
et ses appuis la question sur la
réussite de la france dans le monde
c'était une réussite emblématique il a
extraordinairement réussi c'était dans
les journaux dont c'est malheureux c'est
très mal aux quelques réactions sur ce
sujet d'abord à la question peut-il
rester à la tête de renault
vous êtes 79% à dire que non c'est pas
possible
anti mac nous dit je ne sais pas s'il
peut rester mais je suis un peu déçu de
voir un dirigeant aussi anglais aussi
emblématique et talentueux mise en cause
donc ça rejoint tout ce qu'on vient de
dire babineau nous dit aussi l'idée de
ruissellement par le haut de macron ne
semble pas fonctionner finalement il ya
sans doute une part d'ironie
nicole on nous dit on c'est aussi que
les japonais n'aiment pas voir des
étrangers diriger leur entreprise et oui
il avait été porté aux nues je commence
vraiment le fun et dominique qui ajoute
reconnaissons le grand professionnalisme
de cet homme qui fait de renault qui a
fait de renault ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
on aura sans doute l'occasion de
reparler de tout cela alors les villes
et jaune maintenant c'est un double
visage peut-être que montre le
gouvernement aujourd'hui celui de la
fermeté de christophe castaner qui fait
lever les blocages et celui de jean yves
le drian qui met en garde contre une
transition écologique qui seraient trop
brutal pour les français modestes
on va d'abord écouter christophe
castaner il était ce matin sur france 2
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on a une
dérive totale d'une manifestation qui
pour l'essentiel était bon enfant samedi
est d'ailleurs que nous avons laissé se
dérouler le mieux possible en mobilisant
énormément de forces de l'ordre pour les
protéger les manifestants et pourtant
vous avez vu qu'il ya un très très grand
nombre de blessés d'ailleurs y compris
sur nos forces de l'ordre mais on y
reviendra si vous le souhaitez et
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a une
radicalisation avec des revendications
qui ne sont plus cohérentes qui vont
dans tous les sens alors d'un côté la
dérive que dénonce christophe castaner
de l'autre je le disait jean yves le
drian qui parle lui de souffrance il
doit être davantage entendu on l'écouté
également il y à une souffrance qui
s'est exprimé dans le mouvement des
jeunes
c'est une souffrance qu'il faut entendre
qu'il faut comprendre il faut respecter
il faut aboutir à cette transition
écologique faut l'amener en oeuvre mais
il faut faire attention en permanence à
ce que ce ne soit pas ce ne soit pas au
détriment de certaines catégories
sociales c'est la première des
inégalités
avant de parler de d'éventuelles
divergences de vues au sein du
gouvernement
une question avec naulleau finalement
c'est relativement bien joué pour le
gouvernement jusqu'à présent après le
week-end dont c'était quand même assez
agitée 280 à 300 mille personnes dehors
des jets des jaunes des blocages un peu
partout un mouvement approuvé par les
trois quarts des français
aujourd'hui ça se calme bien joué oui et
non parce que le fait que monsieur le
drian s'exprime sur les affaires
intérieures ça prouve qu une certaine
fébrilité c'est à dire qu'on envoie les
personnalités comme comme ça une hauteur
de vue une autorité qui rejoue par la
majorité de français pour essayer
d'éteindre un incendie
autre mauvais signe je trouve qu'ils
utilisent vraiment une batterie
d'arguments à peu tous azimuts ça ça
devient un peu
nouveau pour lépine oui attention parce
que les gendarmes et des policiers
pendant qu'ils surveillent de gilet
jaune ils sont en train de combattre le
terrorisme il ya le bâton et la carotte
ensuite ce que dit le drian est bien
intéressant mais ça n'a rien à voir et
la transition écologique tout le monde a
compris que c'était mesures destinées à
assurer les fins de mois de la fin de
mois du gouvernement
mais moi je crois que ça se joue pas du
tout comme ça c'est que tout le
quinquennat de macron tient sur le fait
qu' il va aller jusqu'au bout que lui ne
va pas reculer c'était la promesse sur
laquelle il s'était présenté devant les
français et circulent c'est fini donc il
ya un bricolage rhétorique pour essayer
de faire passer ça mais il ne reculerons
jamais l élégie les jaunes peuvent
rester trois semaines un mois
macron d'où son quinquennat là-dessus et
il ne reculera pas il a demandé à tous
les ministres de jouer chacun sa
partition
c'est la bonne grille de lecture alexis
je crois qu macro aujourd'hui se disent
à ce qu'il a été élu sur la promesse de
ne jamais réglé je ne crois pas qu'à
l'époque c'est sur sa promesse là qu'il
est élu d'études sur le stress de
renouvellement d'empathie de
bienveillance de côté de genèse de
coolitude il est pas il n'a pas été élu
je dis pas que c'est à mon président de
reculer en politique c'est un autre
sujet mais je ne crois pas qu'il ait été
élu là dessus et effectivement moi je
pense qu'au départ il aurait dû reculer
mais pas reculer sur une réforme une
augmentation d'impôts c'est pas une
réforme c'est pas la même chose pour eux
quand on dit on dit aux gens maintenant
les zones police augmentera plus tard
plus lente mende est bon il n'a pas fait
ce choix là pour des raisons vous dites
parce que maintenant il s'est persuadé
je pense que edouard philippe contre
bourg beaucoup là-dedans parce que j'ai
l'impression que dans le tandem le plus
ferme sur ces questions là comme sur les
80 km heure c'est edouard philippe
et donc il s'est dit dès lors qui s'est
interdit la solution qui avait des
inconvénients qui était de reculer mais
sur une augmentation d'impôts de 10
rebonds là nul il n'y a plus qu'à faire
quoi ce qui fait c'est des demies
concessions qui marchent pas puis de la
gentillesse on vous écoute mais on vous
donne rien ça marche pas et maintenant
c'est inadmissible en faisant le pari
pas impossible que ça pourri c'est que
ça parte en quenouille
ça veut dire quand même que ça d'être à
des travailleuses cette direction
attendez ça fait but samedi c'est un peu
tôt cette année il ya un signe
inquiétant pour vraiment il faut pas se
réjouir c'est que la cgt en train de
semer le mettre dans la danse la cgt
appelle à une manif dans quinze jours
contre les impôts trop tôt pour crier
victoire
emmanuel rivière pour le gouvernement
lorsqu'on est complètement à côté du
sujet même pour vous dire le fond de ma
pensée
il ya qu' on nous y lisent les agrumes
frappadingue la parler du gouvernement
qui réagit comme si c'était un mouvement
normal c'est pas du tout un mouvement
normal
la première raison c'est que je pense
que ce mouvement existe maintenant pour
lui-même que ces gens qui manifestent et
guéri et jaune trouve ça très jouissif
de faire quelque chose ensemble et de
perturber un système contre lequel ils
sont en train de s'insurger et qu'elles
imitent ils ont à peu près rien à faire
de ce que le premier ministre a pu
annoncer mardi ou ce que le président de
la république a pu conserver comme
déclaration
aujourd'hui le mouvement il existe pour
dire on est là on existe on veut plus
sentir méprisé on veut plus subir une
manière de reprendre la main sur les
choses qui est très profondément ancrée
qui datent pas des manuels macro et
d'ailleurs cette espèce de revanche de
classe qui se considèrent comme des
possédés de quelque chose ce qui pose un
vrai problème démocratique parce que
c'est à dire l'élection de l'année
dernière n'a pas soldé
c'est ce besoin de s'exprimer puis
l'autre l'autre aspect c'est qu'il ya
encore énormément de condescendance faut
pas dire c'est de la souffrance j'ai
même entendu vos victimes etc
ces gens là sont en train de dire quand
on les écoute on est les égos dessus qui
prétendent appartenir aux élites mais
qu'il faut en fait n'importe quoi parce
qu'ils connaissent pas nos réalités il
pas du tout envie qu'on leur dise ben on
va tenir bon vous écoute vraiment mais
on va tenir bon ils ont envie il aurait
envie que symboliquement on les mette
autour de la table pour la faire
participer à la décision
après c'est compliqué parce que leurs
revendications vont effectivement un peu
dans tous les sens donc peut-être que la
cible de 2 de gouvernance ça peut être
ces français qui au départ soutenez les
gilet jaune qui dit joue là là il ya des
débordements et ses mails et gilet jaune
eux mêmes je pense pas que c'est comme
ça qu'on les fera signer d'accord ou pas
d'accord que ça peut aussi recharger à
n'importe quel moment et comme le dit
la rivière je pense que maintenant c'est
plus partagés alors j'étais regarder
chez les philosophes de droite pour le
point de départ du mouvement pour le
départ du mouvement n'est ce pas 2
milliards d'impôts je n'appelle plus à
du budget j'appelle ça de l'atacama
remet ça c'est un peu l'esprit général a
donné en revanche
permettez moi d'apporter à la
politologie un petit grain de gaieté en
revanche pour le début de retournement
possible à travers les innombrables
vicissitudes de la france pourcentage
des emmerdeurs est le seul qui n'ait
jamais baissé et je pense que je pense
que plus sérieusement quoique quoique je
pense que c'est sérieux ces adages ça ne
peut pas marcher
et ça ne peut pas tenir vraiment un
mouvement totalement déstructuré qui
refuse de se structurer parce que je le
point commun c'est qu'il le refuse tous
les porte paroles locaux qu'on a entendu
enfin moi j'en ai entendu quelques-uns
de vaucluse le val d'oise de ecsta 10
mais il est hors de question qu'on ait
un porte-parole national il est hors de
question qu'on se structure et du coup
cette mi 6 et du coup ça peut faire quoi
ça peut faire une espèce de nuit debout
s'effiloche au fils oui mais suzy debout
des antilles beau mais si c'est ça le
bout des antilles bobos ou du vie des
automobilistes
c'est pas un problème c'est blême il
suffit d'attendre patiemment grâce à une
bonne nouvelle pour le gouvernement la
manifestation de la cgt parce que si
c'est repris par les corps
intermédiaires ça va abbas est beaucoup
plus rares après beaucoup plus cher il
ya une récupération maintenant de plus
en plus active de certains partis
politiques ça aussi c'est tout bon pour
le gouvernement qui va dire regardez en
fait c'est manipulée par l'opposition
qui a perdu dans les urnes qui essaye
d'organiser un troisième tour dans la
rue je trouve globalement un mouvement
comme ça si ça devait durer vraiment
submergé le pays on aurait vu quand même
beaucoup plus de monde il me semble
contrepartie de beaucoup plus haut
maintenant aux hawks a annoncé la veille
dans un sondage même figaro bon nom
[Musique]
annonçait que 75% soutenait d'accord
mais que 15% était totalement sûr d'y
participer
ce qui fait 7 millions cinq cent mille
personnes qui le vendredi disait jeudi
et vendredi ont dit nous sommes
totalement sûr d'y participer
les 7 millions 500 mille sont devenus
selon dupont aignan cinq cent mille à un
million après apprécier la précision des
études du poignon de toi entre 500 mille
et un million et sur quelle base on sait
pas et en vérité sur les chiffres autour
de l'entée 104 a rassemblé 300 mille
trois cent mille temps des faux pas
enfin il passait pas cette vision et
demi non mais c'est pas le peuple
non non pas mais pas aucun mouvement
social ne commence par un raz-de-marée
la question que vous posez la première c
est ce qu'ils peuvent à partir l'a
construit quelque chose et là c'est vrai
c'est très long qu'un mouvement social
n'a été l'objet de l'incroyable
mobilisation médiatique de la semaine
qui a précédé par vous n'avez pas suivi
mais le mend a laissé les fans un fort
absolument terrifiant le relais pour
regarder écouter sinon ça ne m'arrive
pas regarder tous les jours bien sûr
mais c'est chaque fois qu'il ya très
mais comme ça on vous dit pas mais la
loi y compris les chaînes info vous
disais pas bien dès 6 heures du matin
mais seront spécial pour venir donner la
mort mais pour tous ces journées
l'avènement des chaînes info et vous le
savez parker c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
moindre événement dure une journée deux
journées de la journée que c'était un
truc exceptionnel parce qu'ils ont péri
ce coup de génie de gilet jaune parce
qu'il ya en général dans le pays
basile macro bien coppula pour toutes
les raisons que vous voulez eh bien on
fait d'un feuilleton et c'est un
événement qui a été vers extraordinaire
non plus boudé par bfm maintenant je
pense que c'est trop oui oui ah mais ça
n'est enfin aller expliquer ce trou des
halles finale a remporté l'élection dès
qu'il ne faut pas chercher à glisser sa
part en part par le phénomène bfm qu'un
mouvement qui ne part de rien comme le
dit très justement il n'y a pas de
structure derrière on n'y a pas
d'association où il n'y a pas de chef
parts et commence à 300 milles
c'est du jamais vu c'est triste quand
même important c'est un point de savoir
si ça va encore grosse ayant séleucides
à l'envers on commencera par groupe ares
les verts petit tout mouvement social
dont tout l'est alors vous citiez vos
leaders de droite mais tout vous a été
lecture elle audiard tout le monde sait
que qu'un mouvement social ça s'organise
ça se bâtit sa ce séquence depuis depuis
léon trotsky tout le monde sait ça c'est
le contraire j'ai dit brisées se référer
à son label voilà c'est bien celui-ci
donc là qu'apparaît contraire ça veut
dire que c'est un départ très fort rien
ne prouve que ça va arriver à construire
derrière je n'ai dire que c'est faible
non c'est pas faire la neige était
complètement différente si en effet il
eu 7 millions de personnes là il ya même
plus d' analyse à faire c'est le raz de
marée c'est la révolution salut 300000
je pense que ils font bonne figure
ces déçus non je pense qu'ils sont déçus
par rapport au battage qui a eu par
rapport aux annonces
il n'y a pas de leader il ya quand même
quelques mineurs roi saint jean mouro
disait vous allez moi c'est vrai quelque
chose d'incroyable on va s est mis
mignon mais j'avais vu sur le poteau
bien du tout trois cent mille c'est une
grosse manif intersyndicale allemand
media chiffre en fait on arrive à faire
parler les chiffres que si on a des
éléments de comparaison
et là il nous manque quand même
cruellement ces éléments de comparaison
ces groupes que vous n'avez pas parlé ça
s'est produit l'année je fais
l'hypothèse non ce n'est pas si on rien
que ça mais ses ambitions deviennent
attentifs à ces cours je fais
l'hypothèse là encore en plaçant sous
l'autorité du spécialiste qu'alexi que
si les chaînes à fois on en parle et
c'est qu'elles ont constaté que
l'audience c'était la folie que les gens
adhéraient que ça les insectes qui avait
une curiosité qui avait une arme il y
avait quelque chose donc les chaînes ne
crée pas d'elle-même purement et
simplement un mouvement c'est parce que
je l'attends soulisse qu'on a après la
sympathie et la de s'initier à rien je
crois que on se fait une fausse idée
pourtant déjà ce que vous participerez %
des gens ça veut dire 'est-ce que vous
mettrez votre gilet jaune sur votre
plage avant cela ses discours plus que
300 milles donc c'est c'est un mouvement
sous s'en sort bien
non non non retour et je vous dis mais
vous vous raisonner comme si c'était
prête vous raisonner sur un truc
inorganisés spontanée cela comme si
c'est un truc militaire lancée par un
syndicat non pour un truc spontané c'est
colossal dont les avantages ne voulait
rien viable dans les sondages les
sondages qui veut dire que 80% des gens
le soutiennent vous en connaissez
beaucoup des personnages qui dit qu'il
ya eu sur la grille au séparateur mais
le jeu réagir alors parce que participer
ça va être ça veut dire aussi ce à quoi
faire lever le pouce en passant devant
eux puisque ça mouvement de protestation
beaucoup plus globale dormir tranquille
mais bien sûr les débats tant d'énergie
à tout moment parce que c'était la
question qui nous occupe est aussi non
mais je crois qu'il ya trop d'éléments
contraires il ya le fait qu'en effet les
revendications sont complètement et
papiers parce qu'on entend on veut
simplement la suppression de la taxe et
puis on veut que macron s'en aille ou
alors on veut que mâcon reste mais on
veut que le gouvernement s'en aille
voilà des solutions donc ça devient un
peu et franchement autant le gilet jaune
en effet c'était un coup de génie autant
ils n'ont pas trouvé la revendication ci
s'était tenue à écouter on est 7
millions et on va rester là jusqu'à ce
que vous
supprimer la taxe oui mais là bon et le
noyau dur va rester mais les gens qui
sont de bonne volonté qui adhèrent se
disent ça commence à devenir un peu
n'importe quoi moi je pense que ça va
s'effilocher et que ça va être pris en
compte par les corps intermédiaires
je vois par la stratégie du gouvernement
que parce qu'il faut absolument et je
trouve qu'il ne joue pas très bien
commencé dans cette affaire demande
n'est pas de fixer noël aux incendies
alors le sur cette question w nous dit
le mouvement ne fait que débuter c'est
son opinion et des deux braves gens ça
doit être le surnom d' autres
internautes
ah non de braves gens pendant se
permettent quand même de porter atteinte
à la liberté de mouvement des 99 % de
français sans gilet c'est tellement une
dimension le problème sans souligner
c'est le côté s'est débloqué des gens
qui eux mêmes se passe quelque chose
d'étonnant et en effet on l'a vu sur bfm
et d'ailleurs c'est que comme personne
ne veut risquer maintenant l'étiquette
infamante d'être contre le peuple on
n'ose pas dire maintenant parce que nous
on veut pas être taxé de populisme à
l'envers en dix ans excusez moi mais
enfin ça a bloqué qui monsieur macron il
s'est baladé en allemagne ça a pas l'air
de l'avoir bloqué ensuite en belgique
c'est à bloquer plus tôt d'autres
français qui sont pas tellement mieux
loti que le danger des gens soutiennent
plutôt le truc ça les emmerde être
bloqué l'accord une fois entre les deux
une fois peut-être pas nous voir et nous
quand même à crêpes de penser qu'un
mouvement d'automobilistes les incidents
ont été des incidents entre mobilisent à
convaincre
sont bloqués sont pas contents mais les
mêmes dans les sondages et ce qu'ils
soutiennent le mouvement sauf que quand
ils sont d'ailleurs à ce barrage dès
maintenant je vais passer et je l'aimé
courses à faire les enfants vivent là
c'est un amalgame est comme ça mais en
en faisant les cents pas bien grave
puisque ça a été créé par bfm et que
c'est rien du tout et je pense que ça va
parce que même les internautes du figaro
ne demande pas la dissolution mais c'est
un produit c'est juste ça va bien au
delà
et c'est un malaise qui laissera des
traces bien au delà de la simple
question de la taxation du gazole et de
l'essence c'est une espèce de
revendication identitaire culturelle
sociétal global qu'on peut relier à la
sphère de gosné de le même pas de la
france d'en haut du monde dans parce que
c'est pas la france d'en haut c'est là
c'est les pays d'en bas contre le monde
d'en haut qui nous est finement silva de
qualité de capitalisation en avion ça
laissera des traces et le gouvernement
et nova voilà qui donne le point de vue
des meilleurs hiver qu'il faisait sans
doute regarder voir est et voit l'ailé
les participants séquelles france mais
c'est la france des classes moyennes
inférieures c'est la france qui
effectivement en fait comment ils se
mobilisent au départ c'est effectivement
sur la question de la fiscalité du
carburant mais c'est avant tout sur ce
que ça veut dire pour quel est le
premier mot que les gens associent quand
on leur parle de l'automobile l'univers
de l'automobile liberté si une entrave à
leur liberté qu'ils ressentent d'avoir
besoin de compter et donc de moi
circuler parce qu'en fait l'alternative
il estime ne pas en disposer
ils sont mis sous tension ces gens parce
que paris bien sûr pas complètement
indifférent questions environnementales
quoi qu'on raconte mais simplement mis
sous tension est sommé de faire quelque
chose alors qu'en fait quand on fait des
gestes environnementaux le pouvoir en
est fier donc pour elles servent à
quelque chose de l'avoir choisi
mis sous tension ils disent vous
n'offrez pas les solutions donc ce que
tout ce que vous voulez faire c'est nous
taxer et en fait c'est pour boucler vos
fins de mois que vous faites ça mais par
ailleurs je pense qu'il est enfin moi
j'ai été frappé à plusieurs reprises de
voir les gens vraiment interrogé dans
les micro trottoirs sur ce que disait
philippe emmanuel macron l'eau et
répondant à la question est qu'est ce
que vous allez faire à berre va
continuer et là c'est de la joie qu'on
voit ces gens qui chantent la
marseillaise sombrement
il ya quelque chose d'absolument
incroyable qui complètement lié à un
phénomène qu'on mesure par ailleurs dans
des études mais tu te crois bientôt au
grand public sur les valeurs des
français qui est un mélange de besoin de
collectif et besoin d'en découdre et les
gilet jaune sur la table à
l'intersection d'une salle d'eau et plus
tristes de la sphère plus prosaïque ces
camps en effet l'augmentation des taxes
correspond à une surcharge de plusieurs
dizaines d'euros strictement pour des
gens qui ne peuvent pas lequel les
dépenses et pas seulement la joie c'est
que simplement on taxe des gens pour
aller travailler au fond il ya des
régions de france où je ne pouvais pas
passer de la voiture les culpabiliser et
ce à des coûts l'exaspération contre les
gens jouent parce que non seulement ils
nous piquent notre pognon mais en plus
ils nous disent qu'on est des salopards
de l'utiliser dans une voiture alors que
là et donc ça non normande
c'est une de ces donc c'est des mines
des frustrations et qu'effectivement de
l'élection présidentielle n'a pas purgée
est sûre qu'elle a sans doute mis à de
nombreux dons parce qu on a vu cette ce
score très important de de maquereaux
second tour mais cette france là ne se
retrouve pas dans le résultat l'excès
résidentiel et finalement à voter
souvent n'a pas votre demande s'il a pas
de manquer un vrai second tour je suis
pas du tout en train de rendre moins
légitime l'élection des maires a conquis
les totalement dans le forage dans les
élections mais quelque part il n'y a pas
eu cette dramatisation du débat de
second tour qui fait qu' on se dit bon
vaut mieux macron que celui qui a
vraiment un moment on représente douce
elle car vraiment représenter un danger
en fait je pense que pour ces gens là
marine le pen n'a pas vraiment présente
un danger soit parce qu'ils ont voté
pour elle soit parce qu'ils ont jamais
cru qu'elle pouvait être élu on verra
samedi
ce qu'il en est pour la suite immédiate
je rappelle juste là le résultat de
notre question du jour qui était en
ligne depuis déjà plus de 24 heures et
qui a fait plus de cent mille votes
c'était assez partagés et c'est toujours
ce résultat
c'est jaune doivent t'ils poursuivre
leur mobilisation
c'était 52% enfin ses 52% que c'est très
très rare que vous soyez moitié-moitié
comme ça ça montre effectivement le le
question assez contre l'idéologie la
sociologie mais voilà c'est le mot de la
fin pour ce thème lui même écarté alors
le thème suivant il n'est pas sans lien
avec les gilet jaune c'est celui des
mères les mères sont souvent les
premiers à recueillir les doléances des
français alors on le sait et emmanuel
macron n'ira pas à leur congrès mais
entre le président de la république et
les représentants des communes les
relations sont effectivement toujours
tendue les raisons du mécontentement
elles sont nombreuses la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation arrive en tête
avant d'en parler en écoute françois
baroin président des maires de france
il dit ne pas vouloir d'une
caporalisation une commune c'est pas une
succursale de l'état on commet une
filiale les moeurs et des élus ils sont
mandatés c'est pas des fonctionnaires
ils sont pas là pour avoir le petit
doigt sur la couture et agir sur ordre
on est des agents de l'état dans
certaines missions et on est élus
mandatés donc aux cantons emmanuel
macron reconnaissait la semaine dernière
qu'il n'avait pas réussi à réconcilier
les français avec la politique et ne pas
se rendre dans les maires de france
habile maladroit pas très habile là
encore parce que qui un peu comptait
aussi parmi les différents reproches
faits cet exécutif celui là alors perdu
le contact avec les réalités et
notamment avec les territoires
ce sentiment l'ayant les français qui
ont été interrogés et là dessus je crois
pas mes confrères de l'ifop sont exprimé
très clairement dans le sentiment que la
politique qu'ils étaient effectués
étaient une politique qui négligeaient
les communes rurales et petites communes
ce qui est maintenant devenu une qu'il
lecture les maires pouvaient jouer un
rôle d'intermédiaire par rapport à ça ce
qui est ressenti par beaucoup d'élus
locaux par ailleurs c'est que par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs
emmanuel macron leur donne le sentiment
d'être moins à l écoute de ce qu'ils
auront à transmettre ce qu'ils ont à
exprimer plus aller coûte 2
voilà peut-être de fonctionnaires
sachant et là aussi un petit sentiment
de déséquilibrer une jambe qui est moins
complète et puis par ailleurs sur cette
thématique de la taxe d'habitation
c'est un curieux comme comme comme choix
et parce que finalement les lectures qui
est fait de ce qu'est devenue la taxe
d'habitation c'est que ces choix du
gouvernement puisque c'est le
gouvernement qui en parle arriver à un
résultat ou plein de français ont le
sentiment finalement la taxe
d'habitation a augmenté qui se sont fait
avoir tout au passage tout en ayant au
passage un quelque chose mal contrôlé
sans doute sur le balance tournaire il
pense qu'il a été modérément appréciée
par cette assemblée maire vous m'en
donnez pas c'est l'extrait un autre
extrait de françois baroin qui fait
allusion à cette histoire de balances
ton mer et qui a peu apprécié ministre
qui est en charge du budget qui
utilisent l'administration fiscale pour
publier une liste de gens qui augmente
la taxe d'habitation ne respecte pas en
quelque sorte l'esprit la lettre la
constitution puisque la libre
administration des collectivités locales
est garantie par notre loi fondamentale
un maire qui augmente ses impôts ne le
fait pas pour faire plaisir à un
gouvernement ou faire des plaisirs un
gouvernement en général ils les augmente
parce qu'il a des projets parce qu'il a
des devoirs parce qu'il ya une structure
qui est lourde peut-être parce que
d'être gay structure et avant lui c'est
pour cela alors il n'y a pas d'âge
précis nom dont on peut s'inspirer
il disait le philosophe alors quand les
types de 130 kilos d'ici à quelque chose
voilà quand les types de 130 kilos
disent certaines choses
ceux de 60 kilos les écoutent moi je
traduis quand les types qui voit 130
électeurs tous les deux jours disent
quelque chose
les types qui n'en voit que 60 tous les
deux mois devrait les écouter tout ça
dans cette affaire mais il a fait très
chaud
absolument et après il faut pas
seulement les écouter il faut aussi
donner le sentiment de les écouter c'est
toujours la même histoire d parfois il
peut dire qui c'est que il a passé un
temps infini avec les élus des
différentes régions et qui traversait
dans son sa balade alors qu'est ce qui
là vous êtes son conseiller et il vous
dit ce qu'il faut que j'aille il ou pas
je pense que deux conseillers sur trois
disent ça va se faire siffler du feu de
dieu et oui à faire tous les 20 heures
c'est peut-être que maintenant c'est
qu'il avait pris l'engagement au nid
l'année dernière se souvient monstre de
cette annonce on arrive n'est pas le
premier jamais je ne vais pas le premier
défilé
moi je me suis l'un des packs ou sarkozy
s'était fait il avait envoyé fillon et
filles ont alerté la salle d re tourner
la page
alors est-ce que edouard philippe
retournera la salle parce qu'il va nous
parler jeu contre passion verra bien
bassem appel à pas très bien parti mais
je me souviens très bien de cet épisode
ça veut dire que malgré tout les
bagarres entre le fond l'état l'état qui
quand il ya des économies budgétaires
affaire a toujours tendance à dire c'est
les collectivités qui dépensent trop
date elles datent pas d'hier c'est vrai
que le symbole l'a22 alors qu'on
reproche à maquereau ne pas être au
contact avec la réalité du terrain
enfin en gros c'est ces technocrates qui
nous gouvernent le fait de les gilet
jaune à jour on le way et puis ensuite
les mêmes les maires on n'y va pas alors
que les maires quand même cdc des élus
c'est ça fait mauvais effet je peux
comprendre en terme d'image qui veulent
pas mais peut-être qu'il aurait dû y
aller c'est le directeur honnête il s'y
était engagé nom déjà
oui mais c'est pas bien deuxièmement il
y avait l'occasion de faire preuve de
panache mais pas mal c'est la preuve de
panache
troisièmement il y avait une occasion
incroyable il s'adresse aux gens qui
représentent les gilet jaune en fait
dans cette france rurale où la france
périphérique comme dirait guy lui il y
avait l'occasion en or de leur dire
écoutez il ya la taxe d'habitation
il ya l'augmentation des taxes mais tout
ça fait partie d'un plan global et je
vais vous expliquer que c'est bon pour
vous parce que en effet vous allez
dépenser de l'argent mais nous en
contrepartie nous allons faire ceci ou
cela pour juste parfaite ni les petits
films à d'étonnantes
qu'il n'ait pas tenté le coup moi je
pense que ceci le signal d'une perte de
confiance en soi
je pense qu'à quelques mois il y aurait
pourtant est le meilleur de tous il y
serait allé et peut-être que ce même
marché
et là je pense qu'après que l'épisode
notamment d'itinérance machin où ils
étaient ils devaient aller au contact
s'est fait engueuler engueuler je pense
qu'il ya énormément alexis je crois que
c'est pas ça moi je crois simplement que
il a loupé l'occasion de présenter un
plan global parce qu'il n'y a pas de
plan global que ce gouvernement cody et
se retient il manque un peu d'argent là
je vais le prendre là tiens il en manque
un pelage et que ya pas de paix global
hougaard aplon dutil a dit j'ai échoué
nana oui quand il a dit j'ai échoué à
réconcilier les français avec les
actionnaires
moi j'ai trouvé comme cave et du
désarroi dans son regard et je pense que
le fait de pas y aller
enfin je suis absolument j'ai pu c'est
de la psychologie vous ne me dira 3 3
balles mais je suis sûr qu'il ya six
mois il aurait dit je veux leur montrer
je vais retourner au travail il en émane
toujours avoir quelque chose à dire moi
je pense qu'il a rien leur invention qui
auraient pu y aller
ouais moi je moi même à subir des huées
qui aurait fait les 20 heures oui je
pense moi aussi moi j'aurai je pense que
ça aurait pu retourner une partie de
l'opinion mais je crois qu'en face à
l'allemand la salle a peut-être non mais
je crains que non mais ça aurait pu
s'arranger un peu mais je crois que
fondamentalement macron et ceux qui ont
voté pour lui ont fait le pari qu'il y
aura désormais une france à deux
vitesses et kong ouverte uniquement pour
la france non moi je crois que c'est ça
et qu'il n'a pas la classe plus personne
il n'a rien à leur dire
il n'a rien alors qu'il passait les
français disent quand françois baroin
tard dans le figaro d'ailleurs disais il
faut une nouvelle phase de
décentralisation est ce que finalement
on se dit pas aussi bon ben ça fait 30
ans que ça dure et n'a pas produit des
effets quand même formidable sur tous
les plans la décentralisation est ce
qu'il faut aller encore au delà les
français sont toujours pour la
décentralisation quand on leur pose la
question et il en parle spontanément à
peu près
à peu près jamais donc je pense que
c'est pas trop le sujet mais le par
contre il ya un sujet enfin si on suit
et je serai très tenté de la suivre la
logique de ce qui a été dit jusqu'à
juste avant un d un des points clés de
ce quinquennat c'est la confiance
franck rouas qui s'adresse maintenant le
maquereau s'adresse à ceux qui sont
censés faire redémarrer l'économie de ce
pays d'une part et ses homologues
européens et c'est pour ça qu'ils aient
voulu être crédible sur les questions
budgétaires et pour que ça marche il
faut que ça redémarre la confiance
revienne dans ce pays est on en train de
dire là est en train de montrer
d'ailleurs que ce gouvernement pas
tellement confiance dans les français
vraiment c'est décidément ces gens qui
comprennent pas grand chose il faut leur
expliquer leur expliquer il n'y a pas
vraiment confiance dans les mers qui
sont leurs représentants parce que ça
risque de mal se passer
et si on ajoute à ça l'hypothèse sur
laquelle il n'aurait pu tellement
confiance en eux mêmes ça répond me gave
s vous pourrez obtenir la confiance il
faut un avoir confiance en soi de faire
confiance aux autres parce que la
confiance est quelque chose à pau
réciproque manque de confiance du
gouvernement groupe eda et que mollo de
dire que
ils ont fait décidé de s'occuper que de
la france en eau et de laisser d'abord
en france si c'est ça alors là pour le
coup c'est alex descas raison venir on
peut pas être trouve pas parler de corde
et c'est une expression qu'il met mais
c'est pas dans l'idée c'est pas dans
l'idée et je coupe la corde et les
autres tombent à c'était dans l'idée
vaut et prennent les premiers corners
vont permettre à tout le monde de monter
cette idée ne peut pas être perçu comme
vrai par les français mais elle ne veut
pas dire la traduction qui s'imposent si
on vous suit je coupe la corde parce
qu'on souffre je m'en fous des trains va
si je lui ai dit tu m'en fous non non je
vais je crois les traînées parce qu'on
ira au sommet il ya peu l'idée je vais
faire leur bonheur malgré 20 mai
regardez comme vous savez comprennent
deux sommes dans une phase qui passe
même tout et tout est totalement quoi
qu'ils disent est quoi qu'il fasse
inaudibles parce que c'est une phase
trop difficile à la médiacité tout à
l'heure baroin qui disent il faut une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
vous avez un projet de révision
constitutionnelle en cours sur lequel il
ya une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation sur lequel il a
autorisé des régions à faire des
différenciations par rapport à des
normes nationales ferez crever le
moindre jacobins s'il était d'abord le
frère tourner six fois dans sa tombe
et personne ne le sait et c'est la même
droite peut-être pas baroin lui-même et
tout mais qui est en train d'essayer de
bloquer d'empêcher la révision que c'est
donc une des porte paroles et les plus
brillants dit il faut une nouvelle étape
donc c'est quoi qu'il dise quoi qu'il
dise on ne les entendra pas ce qui fait
que leur principale erreur je pense
aujourd'hui mais comme nos lauriers
brésil je ne suis pas conseiller à
l'elysée si réalité et si on y est ils
tous les trois ce serait je voyais
jamais de la vie pour rien au monde
mais ça change les jeunes oui bah oui
non mais c'est justement pour ça que
j'étais tellement à mehal vous aussi
sympa vous donner si vous parlez vous
même c'est plausible
alors du coup vous allez me faire perdre
votre plaisir
les haussiers non justement c'était plus
du tout alors là ça y est j'ai dit il au
début ils nous disent et dans ces cas
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand au moins on
parle pas tout le temps et l'erreur
c'est de parler de l'auto selon vous
emmanuel macron aurait-il dû se rendre
au congrès des maires de france
oui mais vous êtes en deçà 79 % de oui
avec nicole qui dit emmanuel macron
donne l'impression de se dégonfler
devant une assemblée de mer en colère
dominique qui ajoute refusé de s'y
rendre pour convoquer les maires par la
suite il fait sans doute allusion au
fait que ils sont conviés à l'elysée
pour une délégation d'entre eux c'est
non seulement un manque de respect mais
aussi un semblant de crise d'autorité on
termine avec je ne vais pas vous faire
mentir olivier disant qu'à chaque point
de vue on abordait l'islam d'une façon
d'une autre pour ça qu'on a décidé de
paris la loi de 1905
alors est-ce un totem auquel il ne faut
surtout pas toucher au contraire est-il
nécessaire de l'adapter pour payer
permettre une meilleure intégration de
l'islam en france
c'est en ces termes que le débat est
posé le figaro veille consacré trois
pages demain que vous aurez j'espère
l'envi de lire depuis plusieurs jours le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner reçoit les représentants des
cultes sur le sujet est donc ce jeudi ce
sera au tour des
musulmans du cfcm alors on peut voir
comment le ministre de l'intérieur
justifie cette réforme lui dit comme on
le voit s'afficher à l'écran ça fait 113
ans qu'on n'a pas que la loi existe on
ya peu touché donc il est temps de la
réforme et sa collègue ministre des
territoires jacqueline gourault dit elle
que c'est un sujet à manier avec la plus
extrême prudence on les écoute
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat qu'il
faut manier avec beaucoup de prudence
monsieur castaner a dit cette phrase ça
n'est pas tabou moi je dis pas qu'il ne
faut pas le faire je dis simplement que
c'est dans notre pays
quelque chose de très sensible et de
très fragile
alexis csat ya une réforme nécessaire ou
c'est ouvrir la boîte de pandore
moi je suis gouro 17 fois mieux on se
porte
je pense que d'hab on sait pas quel est
son objectif est ce que l'objectif c'est
de contrôler l'islam
d'abord ce n'est pas l'objectif affiché
tous ceux qui ont essayé honte échoué et
sarkozy le premier et dieu sait qui
c'est des nues mal et qu'il décide de
nommer un islam à sa botte ça ne marche
pas parce que c'est une religion où il
n'ya pas de clergé donc pas de
représentant et donc on met en scène les
uns y en a d'autres qui se lèvent pas
derrière que c'est extrêmement compliqué
qu'on a une règle du jeu aujourd'hui qui
la loi de 1905 que comme le disait
qu'est-ce-qui désaxé castaner elle
existe depuis je n'ai pas touché en plus
c'est pas si on n'y touche on ya tous et
je crois que la transparence financière
la loi la loi le permet aujourd'hui on
peut très bien faire le il ya du trac
fin on peut très bien savoir
on sait par exemple que la russie a
donné de l'argent là il ya d'autres
moyens de contrôler les financements la
formation des imams
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'une
formation alors oui c'est en fait c'est
le concordat mais lorsqu'il faut le dire
mais on veut pas le dire
la seul endroit où on peut former des
imams c'est aujourd'hui à strasbourg il
ya une formation où on enseigne à peu
près n'importe quoi des gens qui n'ont
aucun d'ailleurs des imams parce que
aucun gars qui veut être imam ne va là
bas
donc tout ça n'a pas de sens parce qu'il
faut laisser si les fidèles musulmans
veulent financer des lieux de culte ils
peuvent les financer il ya par ailleurs
des tas de facilité de d'établissements
culturels qui permet de les financer
et puis après pour surveiller les
prêches il faut faire ce que fait
aujourd'hui la lah des séries c'est en
formant les imams con qu'on arrivera il
faut juste envoyé de la police quand il
regarde skis 10 points fausse bonne idée
eric naulleau déjà c'est pas le drian
que s'expriment sur les questions
intérieures madame goro sur la loi de
1905 cela devient un peu cacophonique la
nôtre notre gouvernement neuf mois mais
la position du sujet en ce moment assez
sérieux et si les ambitions six
ministres modem pour qu'elles s'y
consacrent hamas aux politiques
d'inspiration démocrate chrétien pour
lesquels le point de vue de l'église
catholique compte et l'église est très
réticente à ce qu'on modifie quoi que ce
soit les protestants aussi et c'est une
femme politique on peut pas à la fois
dire si jupiter il laisse personne
dépassée il est personne dire un mot il
reste
on du sujet ce n'est pas leur coeur du
sujet alors êtes vous retirer votre
marque il a promu un mois ce que d'après
ce qu'on sait évidemment que ces malades
manier avec précaution surtout que ses
associés à la question de l'islam donc
ça fait quand même beaucoup de choses
positives mais d'après ce qu'on en sait
ça ne concernerait que le régime des
cultes - il semble qu'il ya un besoin de
clarification avec l'islam ça me paraît
pas aberrant de vouloir un peu plus de
tarification un peu plus de contrôles
mais en effet là je suis d'accord avec
vous alexis ii c'est que le seul but
c'est de trouver une instance
représentative des musulmans de vent il
n'y a pas d'autres enjeux alors soit ça
fait partie des enjeux de cette réforme
soit ça ne fait pas partie si ça n'en
fait pas partie en effet c'est beaucoup
de bruit pour rien il ya beaucoup de
choses qu'on peut régler mais si ça
permet de régler ce problème je pense
que c'est essentiel on a besoin d'un
apaisement des relations entre l'islam
et la république douala l'apaisement il
passe par quoi on perd la raison la
france est d'aborder ce débat regardez
là vous voyez ça toucher à la loi de
1905 reviendrait à dumbéa les frères
musulmans mais c'est aberrant de dire
des choses comme ça le camp totalement
aberrant d'avoir la loi de 1905 faire
landes et basque on doit toucher ou pas
touchés
on n'y a touché mais je ne sais pas
combien poids mais je ne sais pas la
joie et de toutes les scènes et parfois
sans le mettre dans la loi mais dans le
même temps ailleurs dans le code des
collectivités locales avec 7 mai pour
des ajustements à ses ouïes mélanine à
la question alors il ne fait pas non
plus la personne de le dire on va
supprimer la séparation entre l'église
et l'état donc donc c'est absurde de ça
si c'était quelque chose de l'objectif
c'est exactement l'inversé que parce que
l'on constate une montée considérable
des forces animé par l'étranger
utilisant le biais d'internet
d'implantation idéologique de fermer à
l'écran pour dit alex goude il ya
d'autres moyens
yalla yalla
alors après alors si on est d'accord si
on est d'accord que ça c'est un sujet
important et qu'il faut faire quelque
chose contre cela
après ça devient débat technique est ce
que la bonne façon de faire celle ci ou
ça et comment s'est même pas encore ce
que propose on monte au grand show sur
un touché qui est absurde puisque le but
serait la verse pas un sujet à agiter
avant les européennes emmanuel rivière
pour cibles européennes ou non
européennes c'est même le sujet le plus
petit faon france aujourd'hui 10 pour
ceux qui effectivement faut aborder les
choses autant que possible avec beaucoup
de prudence
beaucoup de précaution et en évitant les
éruptions calculatrice
après voilà quand on gagne les enquêtes
c'est vrai qu'un problème pose la
question vous un baromètre fait pour la
fédération des peuples sur la société
inclusive on demande aux gens de décrire
la société française et de dire ce qu'il
souhaite
leur description la société française
c'est un tiers une société d'origine
chrétienne un tiers une société
multiconfessionnelle et un tiers une
société laïque
description le souhait ceux ci étaient
d'origine chrétienne un tiers sociétés
multiconfessionnelles 12% société laïque
50% donc à une distance entre le constat
est le souhait est donc il ya un besoin
d'intervention publique sur le sujet ce
qui pose évidemment problème d'écran
dynamiques récolte sur les deux premiers
et l'oeil alors la question était très
très compliqué à construire on a
d'autres questions qui explique ce qu'on
entend par là il est d'ailleurs par l'aï
qu'on entend sur le 1 et 2 mois ses
filles de toutes les religions l'entente
liberté de culte et liberté de
conscience et verte liberté de croire ou
ne pas croire mais derrière tout cela se
cache une réalité enfin se cache pas du
tout d'améliorer une réalité qui est une
majorité de français ont un problème
avec une religion l'islam qui par
ailleurs est la religion de référence
d'un nombre croissant de français donc
il ya un besoin d'intervention est toute
la question c'est de savoir s'il faut
soit touchée à la loi soit 2 d'expliquer
pourquoi cette loi
effectivement là qu'il faut puiser les
réponses parce que c'est celle qui fait
consensus celles qui font consensus dans
ce pays pour
votre répondre ou clarifier ce problème
de religion émergentes qui est plus ou
moins bien accepté mais assez mal
acceptée par un certain nombre de gens
juste un dernier point alexis met
vraiment un dernier mot et puis c'est le
mot de la fin parce qu'on est au bout de
l'émission était quelque chose
formulerait l'alternative un tout petit
peu d'effarement seyssois est-ce qu'il
faut adapter les lois de la république
annezin à cette religion qui pose des
problèmes de perception et de pratiques
que vous avez dit soit ce qu'il faut
conformer plus de force
l'islam aux lois de la république je
pense que la preuve termes d'alternative
l'immense majorité des français n'en
veulent pas
natif 6 il a bien sûr quand on dit qu'on
va financer des mosquées et et financer
la formation des imams sait bien qu va
adapter les lois la république à l'islam
donc c'est le premier temps et donc je
pense que l'immense majorité des
français n'en veulent pas et moi non
plus quant au deuxième terme de
l'alternative qui est ce qu'on va
conformer de force l'islam aux lois de
la république
on pourrait estimer en théorie que c'est
souhaitable mais qu'il faut penser la
violence qu'il a fallu vis-à-vis des
catholiques vis-à-vis des juifs le
l'histoire du grand sanhédrin c'est
d'une violence qu'on a absolument
inimaginable et qui aujourd'hui serait
absolument inacceptable il accepter ça
ne peut pas marcher
ça ne peut pas marcher donc demain les
français n'en veulent pas l'autre ne
marche l'autre ne marche pas donc moi je
pense qu'il faut rien faire ne pas
toucher à la loi c'est la vie deux des
trois quarts de nos internautes de 75%
très exactement qui disent non il ne
faut pas y toucher anti mac cette loi
fonctionne plutôt bien il faut
simplement dire à certains musulmans
extrémistes ils doivent la respecter
citoyen en toucher à la loi de 1905 on
touche à la laïcité pour favoriser une
entre guillemets certaines religions
olivier duhamel voyez on en a parlé on
sait n'aime pas trop écharpe autour de
cette table pour poser comme question mc
on refuse absolument de toucher à la loi
at il raison de temps
merci en tout cas beaucoup à tous les
quatre merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous demain pour un nouveau point
de vue
[Musique]